Teil der Westen liefert Leoparden an die
Ukraine Präsident selenski hat sich
bedankt fordert nun prompt aber auch
Kampfjets wie wird Putin reagieren droht
die Eskalation eines unserer Themen
heute hier bei viertel nach acht mit
diesen spannenden Gästen nach der Messe
Attacke im Regio Zug mit zwei Toten 16
und 19 Jahre alt sagt Bild
politikredakteur Sebastian Geißler wir
müssen offen über die Herkunft der Täter
sprechen das Vertuschen muss aufhören
Unternehmen Menschen vor allem die
ungeimpften haben gelitten während der
corona-pandemie und leiden noch immer
sagt Journalist und Autor Markus
Klöckner und fordert jetzt Gerechtigkeit
für ungeimpfte die Opfer so sagt er
einer üblen Hetze geworden sein
sehr vieles die falsch das meint auch
der ehemalige Regierungssprecher Bela
anders diese Woche kam raus es gab
geheimabsprachen zwischen der Regierung
Herstellern und Social Media Giganten
wie Facebook und Twitter jetzt braucht
es dringend einen Untersuchungsausschuss
sagt anders und noch ein Thema
polarisiert die deutschen Pop-Titan
Dieter Bohlen er beleidigt in seiner
Show eine junge Frau viele sind entsetzt
auch die Tochter von Roberto Blanco
warum Bowlen für Patricia Blanco Schmutz
ist das erklärt sie heute bei uns
jetzt aber das Thema das sehr viele in
atemheld seit gestern steht fest der
Westen liefert Kampfpanzer vom Typ
Leopard 2 an die Ukraine
präsidensky bedankte sich und bat um
mehr Waffen Raketen und Kampfjets auch
der Kreml reagiert und lässt ausrichten
die Panzer die Deutschland in die
Ukraine liefert sein eine direkte
Beteiligung am Konflikt im russischen
Staatsfernsehen wird gefordert
Deutschland zu bestrafen das Thema jetzt
bei 8:15 Uhr Herr Glöckner was glauben
sie stehen wir vor dem dritten Weltkrieg
ja die Situation ist wirklich
brandgefährlich und ich muss sagen ich
bin schockiert wenn ich sehe was hier
passiert was ich vor unseren Augen
vollzieht
die Waffenlieferung die panzerlieferung
sind unverantwortlich also ich kann der
Politik nur vorhalten ganz also wirklich
massive Vorhaltungen machen was das
Parlament was die Parlamentarier sich
hier erlauben das ist unerträglich
wir können diesen Konflikt diesen Krieg
nicht mit noch mehr Waffen beilegen oder
befrieden Waffen töten Menschen und noch
mehr Waffen töten noch mehr Menschen und
es ist allerhöchste Zeit für Diplomatie
und wer etwas anderes sagt der hat
entweder die Geschichten nicht
verstanden er hat den Krieg nicht
verstanden oder er hat die gesamte
Situation nicht verstanden wir haben es
hier und das muss man einfach mal offen
sagen und ich kann nur darüber staunen
und ich bin entsetzt auch über den
Journalismus in Deutschland das ist also
einfach geradezu unmöglich scheint in
Deutschland zu sagen wir haben es hier
auch mit einem Stellvertreter Krieg zu
tun ja richtig ist Putin hat diesen
Krieg angefangen
dafür sollte man ihn zu Rechenschaft
ziehen das kann man in keinster Weise
billigen unerträglich dieser Krieg aber
es ist eben auch so dieser Krieg würde
nicht stattfinden wenn nicht massiv
tiefenpolitisch von US-Seite
interveniert wurde und das muss man
einfach so sehen die USA haben ein
Interesse daran ihren Gegner Russland zu
schwächen
persönlicher Glaube bleiben wir mal bei
den Fakten sehr sehr viel
Panzerlieferungen wurden vom Kanzler im
Bundestag erklärt wurden verteidigt auch
sein Zögern wurde erklärt du hältst
diese für richtig ich hatte die
Lieferung für richtig und ich muss auch
sagen dieser Krieg würde in Wahrheit ja
sofort enden wenn Russland was er als
Adresse
Kriegsverbrechen dort begangen das würde
Enten wenn er sich zurückzieht dann wäre
sozusagen der legitime Zustand wieder
hergestellt und insofern muss man sagen
ihr Waffen töten Menschen ist aber
russische Waffen mit denen das losging
und man tut gut daran da jetzt
gegenzuhalten und zwar auch militärisch
denn es kann doch Diplomatie kann doch
nicht heißen die Ukraine ergibt sich
einfach jetzt hier irgendwie kampflos
sondern Diplomatie muss bedeuten
natürlich darauf hinzuwirken dass wir
Richtung Frieden kommen aber den Frieden
kann es nur geben wenn Russland aus der
UK keine rausgehen und für Russland um
Gottes Willen auch aufhört mit diesen
schweren Kriegsverbrechen mit diesem
Massakern an der Zivilbevölkerung wie
sie in Butcher gesehen haben und so
weiter das ist die Lösung ihre
Ausführung werden meines Erachtens der
Realität nicht gerecht und zwar nicht
ansatzweise es braucht immer zwei ein
Ochsen stößt niemals alleine und in
diesem Krieg ist Putin nicht der
alleinige Player das ist eine Realität
die einfach ja nicht so nicht stimmt sie
können ein Feindbild Putin zeichnen das
ist in Ordnung ich verurteile diesen
Krieg auch diesen Angriffskrieg illegal
zu tiefst hätte Putin niemals machen
dürfen aber das ändert nichts
interessant dass wir es mit einer
hochkomplexen geostrategien gemengenlage
zu tun haben und also bei aller Liebe
oder Kritik berechtigten Kritik an Putin
und das was Sie gesagt haben ja ich kann
das bis zum gewissen Grad nachvollziehen
aber im Großen und Ganzen finde ich es
geht an der Realität vorbei ganz klar
ist die Tatsache es gibt ein Aggressor
es ist ein russischer Angriffskrieg
belaander wie gefährlich hältst du jetzt
die gegenwärtige Situation ich halte
schon für gefährlich und gefährlich her
und ich ich bin aufgewachsen im Kalten
Krieg da war es auch so dass eine
Nachrüstung die westlicher Seite kam als
sehr sehr gefährlich dargestellt wurde
und das massiven Protest gegeben hat
auch dagegen und gesagt würde oh Gott
wenn wir jetzt Mittel stecken Raketen
hier stationieren dann sind wir am Ende
so kam es dann nicht muss man auch sehen
mit Blick auf die Geschichte hier in
diesem Fall ist es so dass die russische
Seite sicher erstaunlicherweise anders
fällt heute schon als gestern gesagt
auch interessiert uns im Grunde diese
paar Panzer die werden ja kein keine
Auswirkungen haben heute schon lässt der
Krimml da erklären nein nein wir sehen
dadurch aus eine Einbeziehung der
Europäer in diesen Krieg hinein und
werten das auch so also das ist eine
verschärfte Gangart trotzdem ich bin der
gleichen Meinung wie Sebastian Geister
das ist alternativlos gewesen hier
musste etwas geschehen um die Ukraine zu
unterstützen aber
bisher höre ich keine leih Erklärung wie
man den aus der Sache rauskommen will
nur dass die Russen diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen dürfen oder andere sagen sie
müssen ihn verlieren oder soll sagt sie
dürfen ihn nicht gewinnen ja aber wie
man da hinkommen will ist mir völlig
unerklärlich und deswegen braucht es
darauf mehr antworten
spannende Satz sind Außenministerin
Annalena baerbock gesagt hat im
Europarat und der heute auch viel
diskutiert wird
we do not do the blame game in Europe
because we are fighting war against
Russia and not against each other thank
you wir kämpfen einen Krieg gegen
Russland und nicht gegeneinander
wederin dort eine Kommunikation die sie
für schlau halten in dieser Situation
eine Außenministerin muss wissen was sie
da sagt da ist ihr offenbar irgendwas
durchgegangen
das ist ja immer schwierig zu ergründen
was das ist in diesem Falle
wahrscheinlich wollte sie zum Ausdruck
geben dass es hier ja eine Solidarität
der Europäer gibt dass man die
zusammensteht aber sie muss natürlich
wissen dass jedes Wort auf dass sie sagt
auf der Waagschale wirkt und gerade wenn
diskutiert wird sind die Europäer jetzt
mittendrin zu sagen we are fighting so
ist das ja auch das diskutiert worden in
den sozialen Netzwerken als würde sie da
implizieren wir alle stehen jetzt
Ausland in diesem Krieg geschickt ist
das nicht ungeschickt ist es auf jeden
Fall stimmst du dazu Sebastian ein
ungeschickter Satz in der jetzigen
Situation der Außenminister absolut also
mich hat der Satz ein bisschen
erschreckt ehrlich gesagt das halte ich
für also grob unprofessionell und auch
also der Diplomatie der deutschen
Diplomatie unwürdig sich so einzulassen
man weiß ja was Sie damit sagen wollte
nämlich wir als Europäer müssen
zusammenstehen und gegenseitig
unterstützen und so weiter aber so etwas
so auszusprechen ist also sehr
gefährlich und das kann möglich also da
sehe ich dann tatsächlich
versehentliches Eskalationspotenzial
wenn sie so unbedarf daher redet bei
einem solchen Thema
als BürgerInnen wie besorgt sind sie
jetzt in dieser Situation haben sie da
Angst Sorge ja ich habe da schon Angst
und Sorgen weil ich denke einfach der
spitzt sich immer mehr zu und man muss
einfach sagen Herr Putin ist ein
ja also solche Aussagen zum Beispiel da
freut er sich glaube ich so ein bisschen
weil das tut ihnen wieder bestärken alle
sind gegen ihn und er wird immer etwas
suchen glaube ich ein jemand der ihm da
helfen wird praktisch dass er sein Krieg
weiterführen kann und ich glaube dass so
eine Aussage wirklich also nicht zum
Frieden führt auf gar keinen Fall viele
Menschen sind besorgt derzeit in
Deutschland auch aufgrund solcher
Vorfälle ein Mann sticht wahllos in
einem Regionalzug zwischen Hamburg und
Kiel auf Menschen ein zwei Männer
sterben erst 16 und 19 Jahre alt
Sebastian der Geister hier aus der
Bildpolitik sitzt neben mir und du hast
eine ganz klare Forderung ja ich muss
sagen ich bin nicht sehr begeistert wie
das Thema medial aufbereitet wurde von
einigen wenn man sich anschaut den NDR
Hamburg beispielsweise der zunächst also
die in den Hintergrund hat die
Nationalität oder Dieter Herkunft
verschwiegen hat und sogar bei Facebook
unter einem Post Hinweise verborgen hat
auf den persönlichen Hintergrund und die
Ankunft des Täters und sogar dann gesagt
hat als Nutzer gesagt haben warum macht
ihr das denn man wird das noch
aussprechen dürfen dass der Mann aus
Gaza stammt dann geschrieben haben naja
das sei führe zu diskriminierender
Verallgemeinerung und viel
Interpretation man wurde die Seite
Freiheiten von Rassismus und das sei
auch keine Zensur sondern diene dem
Erhalt der Demokratie da muss ich sagen
also Journalisten die die Realität da
vernebeln die erhalten nicht die
Demokratie sondern die Sorgen eigentlich
dafür dass wir über diese Probleme nicht
offen sprechen können Sie dadurch auch
nicht lösen können und das ist es in
Wahrheit was auch Extremisten stärkt das
sorgt dafür dass Menschen sich von
diesen Medienmarken abwenden und da sehe
ich eine Gefahr wer so handelt das
Journalist hat aus der flüchtlingskrise
seine vergangenen Jahren nichts gelernt
dass darf so nicht sein wir müssen offen
sagen wer diese Täter sind also Medien
lassen bewusst die Herkunft weg oder
beschönigen teilweise auch Vorstrafen
in die Fall war das oder wurde ganz
offen wir haben einfach verborgen woher
dieser Mann stammt und man glaubt noch
offensichtlich das haben wir ja hier nur
mehr oder weniger schriftlich bekommen
vom Social Media Themen vom NDR Hamburg
dass man damit was Gutes tue und im
Grunde der Demokratie Hilfe da sage ich
das eine gravierende fehlanalyse das
sorgt dafür dass Menschen dann eher
irgendwie in irgendwelche
telegram-gruppen abrutschen und so
weiter und es sorgt vor allem auch dafür
dass die Politik nicht in wahlung kommt
diese Probleme mal zu erkennen und zu
lösen denn wir müssen diese diese Täter
auch offen benennen wir müssen auch
sehen was sind das eigentlich für
Gruppen das sind ja Leute die diese
Profile ähneln sich ja wir sehen auch
wenn der Mann schon ungefähr 12 mal vor
Polizei nicht erschienen in der
Scheidung getreten ist unter anderem
übrigens mit einer Messer Tat und wenn
er vorher inhaft saß und dann rauskommt
und eine solche Tat begeht dann läuft er
nun offensichtlich etwas schief in
unserem Land und das müssen wir
aufarbeiten und auch politisch eine
Lösung zu führen aber ich habe eine
frage
also die Herkunft wieso ist da diese
Herkunft so wichtig ist könnte er jetzt
auch in Deutschland machen also ich
frage jetzt mal wirklich das hat er was
mit hier oben zu tun das hätte jetzt
auch einen Deutscher sein können das ist
tatsächlich möglich aber wir sehen ja
gerade bei dieser Art von taten die sich
ja auch häufen das in vielfach Menschen
die irgendwie traumatisiert sind
vielfach Menschen die eigentlich auch
gar keinen gut der hatte wie sagt man so
eine so eine seltsame
Aufenthaltsgestattung da weil aber auch
seine Staatsbürgerschaft irgendwie
unklar war ist also Palästinenser da ist
die Frage an wen könnte man so jemanden
ausweisen aber das sind Leute die laufen
hier im Grunde ähm
frei rum und wir stellen aber eigentlich
eine Gefahr da und das ist eben das wo
man politische muss und sagen muss wie
kann man wie kann man solche Leute dann
irgendwie auch in Schach halten die
offenbar ja eine Gefahr für Leben sind
also wenn du deine Steuer nicht zahlst
du schneller eingebuchtet ewig also ein
Typ muss manchmal einfach so sagen das
ist vielfach so ja
Blanco sie verstehen aber warum der NDR
beispielsweise die Herkunft verschweigt
sie sagen Täter
also ich bleibe schon bei Täter ist
Täter natürlich klar traumatisiert kann
aber auch ein deutscher kann ein
Italiener es kann jeder sein es ist egal
aber es stimmt schon ich glaube dass da
so eine Lücke ist dass die dass die gar
nicht mal klar kommen mit diesen ganzen
Leuten also die wandern da so durch die
sind einfach die wissen gar nicht mehr
wie sie mit sowas handeln sollen und das
da wirklich der so wahnsinnig ist und in
den Zug ich bin ja heute in Zug
eingestellt
Zug hergekommen was hatten sie für ein
Gefühl ja ein schlechtes weil an sowas
denkt man wirklich nicht also du steigst
in so einem Zug ein sitzt und dann kommt
so ein Irrer mit so einem Messer das ist
ja Wahnsinn also es ist ja echt brutal
ja total ist das sicher aber der in
diesem Punkt war es ja so also wenn es
dazu führt
dass jetzt tatsächlich hier genannt wird
das ein Palästinenser und die Menschen
denken oh Gott die Palästinenser die
sind sehr sowieso alle
messerwütig und oder Arabisch dem
indische Menschen dann wird es natürlich
eine ganz furchtbare Konsequenz davon da
kann ich den NDR wenn Sie bestimmten
bezweckt haben ein bisschen verstehen
aber hier geht es ja um was eigentlich
anderes der Mann hat ja im Jahre 2015
glaube ich hier ist er hingekommen nach
Deutschland es gibt einen Asylantrag der
der wird jetzt seit acht Jahren
bearbeitet und ist nicht entschieden
worden in der Zwischenzeit gab es
mehrere straffälligkeiten von ihm du
hast es erwähnt einmal hat er mindestens
einmal schon ein mit einem Messer vorher
schon jemanden anderen einen anderen
Obdachlosen oder in einer
Obdachlosenunterkunft nicht nur bedroht
sondern auch verletzt da frage ich mich
schon warum ist dieser Mensch dann hat
sie warum ist dieses Asylverfahren noch
offen ganz einfach ist das eine die
Begründung die heute gegeben wurde war
naja von einem Experten den kann man ja
gar nicht abschieben Gesetz wenn man
wollte weil palästinien Palästina oder
gar seid ja noch nicht mein Flughafen
also man könnte ihn sicherlich irgendwo
anders in die Nähe
oder sonst wohin bringen sind
möglicherweise darüber bringen oder in
andere Gebiete drumherum das ist
natürlich so dass die Menschen dann
überhaupt kein Verständnis mehr dafür
haben und dass dies die Distanz vom
Staat noch weiter entfernt
wir haben gerade angesprochen die lange
vorstrafenliste haben da für sie die
Behörden versagt ja natürlich also ich
meine im Grunde genommen ist das ein
Unding das so ein Mensch mit diesen
Vorstrafen mit dem was er verbrochen hat
ja einfach noch draußen ist und so
agieren kann ich meine natürlich müsste
man sich alles im Detail anschauen auf
die richterlichen Entscheidungen und so
weiter aber wir sehen ja immer wieder
dass es Probleme dieser Art gibt und da
muss man sich fragen woran liegt das wie
kommt das ja die Frau lang war das ja
gerade schon gesagt wenn auf andere
Seite jemand ja was relativ
geringfügiges macht und dann erlebt man
mit Hunde auch die hatte der deutschen
Gerichte und dass ich also schon ein
massives Problem und die Frage ist eben
ja warum ist das und natürlich muss man
auch davor ja waren oder vorsichtig sein
dass man nicht alle Menschen ja die
hierher kommen und Schutz suchen
verurteilt das ist natürlich nur ein
ganz ganz ja kleiner Teil aber es gibt
ein reales Problem und dieses Problem
darf man nicht verschleiern oder bin ich
auch bei Ihnen wenn Medien hier
ja einfach nicht korrekt Berichten aus
falscher Zurückhaltung und dann haben
wir auch einen Bruch mit der Realität
und
wenn sie ja sich umhören mit den
Menschen auf der Straße sprechen und
auch da aufnehmen was die Leute einfach
aus ihrer persönlichen
persönlichen Erlebnissen sehen dann ist
sehe ich da eine riesengroße Lücke
zwischen medialer Berichterstattung und
der Realität
für wie wichtig hältst du die Herkunft
der Tesa die Nennung der Herkunft der
Täter kann man damit wirklich etwas
verändern oder für das vielleicht nicht
noch mehr Vorurteile nur die nur die
Herkunft führt natürlich vorurteilt man
sagt da ist ein Araber jetzt eine ganz
platt also jemand der sich nicht so
intensiv damit befasst der wird sagen
sticht wieder drauf da habe ich doch
gesagt alle zurück und sowas warum haben
wir diese Menschen überhaupt überhaupt
nicht fing mit der flüchtlingskrise an
jetzt haben wir diesen ganzen Salat so
ist die relativ einfache Betrachtung des
Problems wofür ich schon bin eine genaue
Betrachtung der Personen die der Täter
ist und wenn es da die teils gibt die
einfach ein nur
wütend werden lassen dass jemand
tatsächlich hier
wie dieser Mann
seit acht Jahren einen einen einen
duldungsasyl oder was auch immer Antrag
hier hat über den keine entschieden
werden und wenn jemand dann mehrfach
Strafe nicht wird und jemanden anderen
dann auch noch tatsächlich auch mit
einer Stichwaffe verletzt da muss man
sich doch die Frage stellen ist dieser
Mann hier noch willkommen man kann den
offenkundig ja auch gar nicht mehr quasi
ausweisen zumindest hat es keinen
vergleichbaren Pferde gegeben da muss
man sich als Innenministerin schon die
Frage stellen ob diese Regelung sinnvoll
sind oder ob man da noch irgendwas
ändert kann also die Details auf jeden
Fall und etwas und deswegen ist es ja
gut dass jetzt in Zukunft hoffentlich
dann schneller darüber entschieden wird
aber diese Kriterien müssen auch so
bedeuten dass jemand wenn jemand
straffällig wird dann auch wirklich dann
zurück muss in diesen Fällen und das ist
sie auf dem Grundig unterblieben und da
hat man versagt Sebastian stellt sich
die Politik die Fragen die Bilder Anna
hier gerade aufgeworfen hat nicht genug
nicht dringlich genug in mein Eindruck
ist das das hat ja auch nennt sich Weser
unsere Innenministerin drauf reagiert
hat aber im Grunde auch nur eher genau
gesagt das ist eine schlimme Tat und so
weiter man ist dann immer sehr
zurückhalten wenn es darum geht
sozusagen politische Konsequenzen daraus
zu ziehen da wird dann schnell
vorgeworfen oder wird irgendwas
instrumentalisiert und wir haben lange
ja gehört das ist ja fast ein
geflügeltes Wort sogenannte Einzelfälle
man muss man sagen es häuft sich schon
sehen also es ist eine bestimmte Täter
Klientel die da diese Probleme macht und
wenn Deutschland ein modernes
Einwanderungsland sein will
Fachkräfte aus aller Welt und so weiter
dann müssen wir auch uns klar machen wie
wir bekommen heißen wollen und wie wir
nicht willkommen heißen wollen und wenn
einem einen Aufenthaltstitel endet oder
jemand auch das Verfahren hat und
Ausreisepflicht ist vollziehbar dann
muss er auch aus Reisen und dann müssen
unsere Behörden auch sicherstellen dass
so jemand unser Land wieder verlässt
aber ist natürlich auch eine Gefahr wenn
man jetzt nur auf diesen Ursprung wo
diese Leute herkommen wenn man dazu sehr
darüber redet dann entsteht ja beim
Bürger auch so eine Art Hass also das
heißt da laufen die dann so durch die
Gegend vielleicht auch gute die jetzt
aus Bagdad oder was weiß ich woher die
kommen und werden angegriffen das habe
ich alles schon gesehen
was wäre die Lösung es ist ja die Löcher
das Problem es gibt eben keine Lösung
weil es ist überall gibt es immer eine
dunkle Ziffer von Menschen es gibt es in
Deutschland es gibt in jedem Land aber
klar Deutschland hat natürlich immer
dieses Problem die Türen sind immer
offen man will ja nach außen zeigen man
ist jetzt nicht rassistisch man ist dies
nicht aber das ist so schwer das ist
einfach echt schwierig weil der Bürger
macht sich ja ein Bild und ich wette
jetzt nach dieser Geschichte wenn man
jetzt ein bisschen dunkelhäutig ist und
seinem Zug rumrennen und ein bisschen
komisch aussieht wird man schon von der
Seite angeschaut also denke ich jetzt
doch so funktioniert der Mensch ja vor
allen Dingen muss man sich einfach auch
noch mal vor Augen führen die Schwere
der strafzahlen die da im Raum stehen
also wir reden hier nicht was weiß ich
von Schwarzfahren
also ich meine das ja das wiegt wirklich
richtig schwer und da muss man einfach
auch die
ja also Jugendämter die nicht ja also
oft genug in so ein Haus gehen wo ein
Kind irgendwie missbraucht wird das ist
leider derselben spielt die Frage ist
halt wurde das verpennt ja ich meine
dann ist einer zum Himmel schreiende
Inkompetenz auf Seiten der Behörden ja
oder gibt es andere Gründe was auch
immer aber ja das ist natürlich
unerträglich
ist natürlich völlig richtig was Frau
Blanco hier auch sagt also es sind
sozusagen die Leute rechts außen sagen
auch die sind alle so die müssen alle
raus und da gibt es von links Leute die
sagen die von denen ist gar keiner so
oder darf man über die gegen die darf
man gar nicht sagen beides stimmt
natürlich nicht wir brauchen die
Realität betrachten wir als Medien
müssen das tun die Politik sollte das
tun dann kann man diese Probleme auch
lösen und dann kam Deutschland auch das
moderne Einwanderungsland sein das ist
ja sein will man setzt nämlich gerade
Menschen auch einer Lesart aus die
vielleicht etwas so aussehen als wenn
sie von
in der Familie Geschichte und so weiter
das sind oft die Leute die dann darunter
zu leiden haben oh da habe ich jetzt
einmal ein gewisses Beklemmung hier wenn
jemand so unser aussieht ähm das heißt
das ist etwas das beschweigen und
verschweigen ist auch was was dann
diesen rassistischen Tendenzen und
Wahrnehmung eher Auftrieb verschafft
vielleicht in der ein oder anderen
Stelle das Maß verloren da sind wir
schon mittendrin in ihrem Thema denn das
hat man ihre Ansicht nach mit der
Behandlung von ungeimpften in der
corona-krise sie sagen die wurden
gehetzt diffamiert wir sind mittendrin
es ist ihre Zeit ja absolut was wir
erlebt haben in der Pandemie
im Hinblick auf den Umgang mit den
unimpften das war so schlimm ich hätte
das nicht für möglich gehalten Menschen
Mitbürger wurden diskriminiert
ausgegrenzt sie wurden bedroht und sie
wurden in ihrem sein als Menschen und
Bürger entwertet und das vor unserer
aller Augen
die es gab eine sprachliche Gewalt die
sich gegen die ungeimpften gerichtet hat
die im Grunde genommen unerträglich war
und mit dieser Gewalt diese Gewalt hat
sich vollzogen über einen langen
Zeitraum und was mich schockiert hat war
wie wir als Gesellschaft damit
umgegangen sind wir haben nämlich
hingenommen wir haben nicht hingeschaut
wir haben im Gegenteil das ganze sogar
in Teilen zumindest auch noch
unterstützt und ähm
aber der Druck war viel zu groß von
allen sein
wolltest oder da der Mensch wurde er nur
noch überschüttet mit diesem Wahnsinn
und du sprichst eine sehr guten Punkt an
es gab einen wirklich unfassbaren Druck
und muss fragen woher kommt wo es her
ist dieser Druck gekommen der Druck kam
von zentralen Teilbereichen unserer
Gesellschaft unserer Demokratie im
Grunde genommen alle zentralen
Schutzräume die eine Demokratie bietet
einer Gruppe die sozusagen unterdrückt
die Familie in grenzt wird und so weiter
ausgegrenzt wird die waren zerfallen von
der Politik ja ging ein unfassbarer
Druck aus auf der einen Seite die Justiz
hat meines Erachtens nicht mehr recht im
Sinne des Rechts gesprochen sondern
recht im Sinne der Politik das ist fatal
für ein Rechtsstaat es gab sicherlich
auch Ausnahmen ja aber meiner
Wahrnehmung war weite Teile der Justiz
haben furchtbar gehandelt und dann
natürlich auch die Medien Medien muss
man ganz schwere Vorwürfe machen
Journalisten haben einen enormen Druck
auch auf die Politik aufgebaut und sie
haben sich quasi als Speerspitze der
pandemiebekämpfung verstanden und da
muss ich sagen das ist nicht die Aufgabe
von Journalisten Journalisten die
Aufgabe von Journalisten ist sachlich
objektiv und sauber zu berichten der
wahrheitsgemäß und der Realität gemäß
und ich kann verstehen wenn Journalisten
sind ja wir sind alle Menschen die einen
hatten mehr Angst vor Corona die anderen
weniger und ich kann verstehen wenn
Journalisten in ihren Redaktionen Angst
hatten ähm ja vor dem Virus das ist das
eine aber wenn sie nicht in der Lage
sind so zu berichten wie sie Auftrag ist
dann sind sie für den Beruf des
Journalisten nicht geeignet und mein
Eindruck war es gab hier sehr viele
Journalisten die auf eine unerträgliche
Art und Weise Anführungszeichen
berichtet haben
sie lassen Sie uns mal bei den
ungeimpften bleiben denn das ist ihr
zentrales Thema jetzt gerade auch in der
Sendung haben sie das selber erlebt die
Vermehrung Ausgrenzung weil sie
ungeimpft sind ja ich habe das vor allen
Dingen erlebt
in meinem Bekanntenkreis also im
Hinblick auf andere ungeimpfte wie mit
denen umgegangen wurde ja es war
furchtbar also ich kann Ihnen zwei
Beispiele nennen eine Freundin
im Kindergarten gearbeitet
jeden Tag kam die Kollegen an und haben
sie gefragt nach ihrem Impfstatus und
haben Druck aufgebaut immer wieder ja
freundlich weniger freundlich mal zum
Ziel mal sehr sehr direkt und ja diese
Frau hat irgendwann diesen Druck nicht
mehr Stand gehalten sie wollte sich
nicht impfen lassen sie war unheimlich
skeptisch gegenüber der Impfung und ähm
hat sich dann zweimal spritzen lassen
und das hat auch etwas beschädigt in
diesem Menschen dieser Frau und das ist
ein Beispiel ein anderes Beispiel war
einfach im Hinblick auf die Maßnahmen
einer junge Frau die keine Maske tragen
konnte aus medizinischen Gründen also
real faktisch keine Maske tragen die Art
und Weise wie der Arbeitgeber mit dir
umgegangen ist was so unerträglich so
schlimm sie hatte einen
Nervenzusammenbruch auf der Arbeit und
Krankenwagen musste kommen und sie ist
jetzt in Therapie das sind einfach zwei
Fälle aus meinem direkten Umfeld die ich
mitbekommen habe live erlebt habe das
heißt die Fälle die ich jetzt gezielt
habe haben sich auf der
gesellschaftlichen Ebene vollzogen und
die Frage ist wie konnte es dazu kommen
dass Arbeitskollegen ja mit denen man im
einen Moment noch ja wunderbar
zusammengearbeitet habe plötzlich sich
angemaßt haben in einer medizinische
Entscheidung die Privatsache ist
einzugreifen sie haben gerade den Kopf
richtig in die Hände gelegt und sagten
flüsterten so leise das kenne ich auch
also was ich erlebt habe waren der
Bäckerei also da gab es anscheinend
jemand der hat das nicht vertragen auch
und der hat die Maske wirklich also das
kann man die da unten getragen und ist
dann eben so rein und ich saß da eben
und der wurde wirklich von allen Seiten
also gut von dieser Verkäuferin die muss
es machen weil sonst kriegt sie
wahrscheinlich fliegt sie aus ihrem Job
raus was weiß ich aber das sind wirklich
fünf sechs Leute auf den Namen auf den
eingeschimpft auf diesen Menschen der
erklärte er hat erstmal er konnte das
irgendwie nicht gut manche machen das
vielleicht weil sie keine Maske tragen
wollen dem habe ich aber echt abgenommen
der Typ ist total verstört aus dieser
Vergleich dann wirklich wie so eine
Masse auf diesen Menschen los
auch darüber geschrieben sie haben sich
mit vielen Menschen unterhalten wie die
Menschen die corona-krise erlebt haben
wie sie Ausgrenzung Einsamkeit Isolation
erlebt haben Familien sind daran
auseinander gebrochen was wurde Ihnen
geschildert im Zuge ihrer Recherche ja
es wurde ein Teil in die Gesellschaft
getrieben und zwar massiv
also wenn ich nur daran denke ich meine
der Titel des Buches heißt lautet möge
die gesamte Republik mit dem Finger auf
sie zeigen das ist ein Zitat das
Redakteurs man hochrangiger Journalist
ehemalige stellvertretender
Chefredakteur der Bild-Zeitung der das
gesagt hat möge die gesamte Republik auf
die ungeimpften ja genau
kommt aus dem dezember 2020 da standen
wir ja vor dem zweiten harten Lockdown
geschlossen das muss man zur Einordnung
dazu sagen und das war wenige Tage bevor
die ersten Menschen geimpft wurden ich
möchte nur dass wir die Erkenntnisstand
genau absolut also es gut einzuordnen es
macht es nicht besser man muss sich mal
vorstellen was das heißt wenn jemand von
uns irgendetwas tut sozusagen eine
moralische Grenzüberschreitung oder so
ja und jemand sagt ja ich muss jetzt mit
dem Finger auf Dich zeigen das ist ja
peinlich das tut ja weh ist irgendwie
auch schlimm wenn ein Journalist der
eine Verantwortung hat gegenüber ja auch
der Öffentlichkeit wenn der zu so einem
drastischen Sprachbild greifen wenn ihr
so drastisch formuliert das eine gesamte
Republik auf die Menschen zeigt die
nicht geimpft sind dann hat das eine
enorme Wucht und hier ist das ist meines
Erachtens eine massive journalistische
Grenzüberschreitung auch wenn das im im
Rahmen der Meinungsfreiheit in Ordnung
ist ja ich bin keiner der irgendwie sagt
man soll so etwas verbieten aber
ja hier wurde meines Erachtens gehetzt
bis zum geht nicht mehr viele Menschen
schildern dass sie sich an den Pranger
gestellt haben während der
corona-pandemie wie hast du das
empfunden wie hast du auch die Sprache
empfunden und das Umgehen miteinander
empfunden in dieser Zeit ich war ja
selber jemand der ungeimpfte oder Leute
die sich nicht haben impfen lassen
kritisiert hat auch hier ich habe zum
Beispiel Joshua Kimmich für seine für
seine Haltung stark kritisiert warum
haben Sie das gemacht weil ich weil ich
der Meinung war dass jemand der
teilnimmt an einem
an einer Veranstaltung wo sich alle
impfen lassen mussten um daran
teilzunehmen was kann die Zuschauer gab
wo alle auch
gefährdet waren nach damaligen
Kenntnissen vielleicht kann ich da
gleich noch einen Satz zusammen nach
damaligen Kind sich zu infizieren ist
dann auch aus meiner Perspektive ein Akt
der ja der Ungerechtigkeit war von
Kimmich zu sagen ich kümmere mich nicht
nur um mich selbst sondern wir sind auch
alle anderen egal so habe ich das damals
gewesen ich habe das nachher allerdings
revidiert ich meine Meinung dann auch
öffentlich geändert hat mir nicht viel
Zuspruch eingebracht wie das eine noch
das andere aber dann bin ich klüger
geworden nur noch einmal zurück vor drei
Jahren um diese Zeiten ja 2000 gab es 59
Fälle in Wuhan die auf einmal aufkamen
wo man gesagt hat oder gibt es Leute mit
irgendwelchen Symptomen das ist so ein
bisschen wie Lungenentzündung wir wissen
nicht was das ist die Chinesen haben
eine Stadt mit 11 Millionen Menschen im
Buren dicht gemacht
Aktien sind in den Keller gerauscht
Trump hat eine Reise nach Europa
geschaut
die Formel 1 hörte auf zu fahren es
waren wenn überhaupt Geisterspiele in
der Pandemie und 4 Milliarden Menschen
waren im April also drei Monate später
zu Hause mussten zu Hause bleiben und
die Weltgesundheitsorganisation hat
erklärt das ist eine Pandemie die ist
noch nie gegeben hat und wir wussten
alle nicht was tut dieser Virus also
vielleicht auch das als Erklärung wie
man damals rangegangen ist und
Trans beurteilt hat ich habe allerdings
meine Haltung dann sage ich jetzt nicht
irgendwie um mit dem Beifall irgendwo
abzuholen aber es war einfach so dass
ich dann doch gesagt habe nein hier muss
man auch mit sowas zulassen was war der
Grund für ihre der Grund war dass das
immer klarer wurde dass Corona
offenkundig eine Krankheit ist die nicht
allein mit Impfungen zu besiegen ist was
uns ja suggeriert wurde am Anfang der
hieß es ja
impfen dann kriegt er es nicht ja und
dann war das durch impfen dass ich noch
mal impfen dann kam dieser berühmte Satz
von der Drosten der beste Schutz ist
dreimal infiziert zu sein möglichst
schwer und sich viermal impfen zu lassen
einfach absolut so und da habe ich
angefangen zu denken Mensch was passt
denn hier nicht zusammen müssen sich die
Verantwortlichen deine Ansicht nach bei
den ungeimpften entschuldigen
wenn man Schuld auf sich geladen hat ist
entschuldigen immer gut würde ich sagen
ich würde auch sagen es ist genau der
Punkt was Mila an da eben angesprochen
hat nämlich wir haben neue Erkenntnisse
gewonnen über Corona ich hatte am Anfang
auch tiefe besorgt deswegen Corona ich
hatte Angst um es offen zu sagen und ich
war sehr erleichtert als die Impfstoff
kam das habe ich einen großen Durchbruch
gehalten der Impfstoff war natürlich mit
dem was man sich davon versprochen hat
am Ende ihr eine Enttäuschung ja es ist
ja man ist möglicherweise auf Jahre
immun und so das ist so alles nicht
eingetreten das muss man auch deutlich
sagen ich freue mich aber warum ist das
in Deutschland eigentlich so dass da wo
andere sozusagen rationalisieren und
sagen wir haben neue Erkenntnisse wir
betrachten die Realität doch nicht so
schlimm und ja Corona ist ja auch
teilweise schlimm gewesen ich kenne
Menschen die haben beide Eltern verloren
durch das muss man nicht ausblenden dass
das ja so war jetzt hat sich aber die
Lage verändert warum ist es in
Deutschland so dass dann manche anfangen
zu moralisieren und zu sagen also wenn
du dich nicht so so verhältst ein
bisschen schlechter Mensch und mit dir
wollen wir am besten nichts mehr zu tun
haben und so das ist ja passiert können
Sie das nachvollziehen die Argumentation
dass man da auch eine Reise der
Entwicklung durchmacht das einem erstmal
versprochen also die Impfung ist die
große Rettung man das natürlich glaubt
und dann nach und nach ist man mehr
Informationen bekommen hat seine Haltung
ändern natürlich also es kommt natürlich
auch auf den Wissensstand an den jeder
hat ja auch die persönliche Haltung eben
Emotionen ja ganz subjektiv hat jemand
Angst hat jemand keine Angst ja
gleichzeitig glaube ich dass wir relativ
früh wussten dass die Gefahr dieses
Virus nicht so groß ist wie sie
gezeichnet wird ja also ich lasse mir
noch gefallen für die ersten zwei drei
Monate dass man da vorsichtig war und
einfach nicht genau wusste was kommt
aber ab einem gewissen Punkt war einfach
klar ähm die Zombie Apokalypse bleibt
aus ja und der Eindruck war wenn man die
Medien eingeschaltet hat die Zombie
Apokalypse findet jeden Tag statt dass
jeder das so kriegt so schnell ja
scheiße jeder kriegt das und irgendwie
jeden Tag hat immer mehr jemanden genau
für die Medien in der medienlogik war
das natürlich ich sag mal ein
glücksfallen Anführungszeichen weil man
jeden Tag eine neue Dramatik schaffen
konnte ja der erste Tode in allen gute
Nachrichten
aber ja der erste Tode in Altwarmbüchen
der zweite in Buxtehude der dritte innen
ja Frankfurt und so weiter und so hatte
man jeden Tag eine Dramatik jeden Tag
konnte man die Zahlen präsentieren und
wenn man sich dann aber mal die Zahlen
angeschaut hat muss man sagen sag mal
was war das eigentlich was habt ihr
eigentlich präsentiert nehmen wir doch
nur mal ja die Anzahl der neuen
Erkrankungen also ich meine wenn ich
jetzt 1000 Leute teste und zehn positive
Fälle habe und am nächsten Tag teste ich
2000 Leute und ich habe 20.000 20 Fälle
und ich sage dann die ähm ja die Zahlen
haben sich verdoppelt ja das hat
natürlich damit zu tun dass auch mehr
getestet wurde und ähm das RKI hat immer
wieder auch Test Zahlen veröffentlicht
ähm ich habe das mal recherchiert und
habe nachgefragt auch bei den Gemeinden
Landkreisen und so weiter wie die Tests
Zahlen zusammenkommen und Abgründe haben
sich aufgetan also entweder gab es keine
Zahlen oder sie hatten eben die Zahlen
aus den Testzentren aber nicht die
anderen Zahlen ja also man hatte einfach
keine gesamtestzahl und man hat im
Grunde genommen es gibt auch Leute die
sagen das war im Grunde genommen wie
eine testpandemie man testet und testet
und testet und man verschärft die
Situation subjektiv dadurch aber in der
Realität war es eben anders und also das
ist jetzt nur ein Ausflug in
Journalismus was man kritisieren kann ja
aber was mich viel mehr interessiert
wenn ich das vielleicht auch mal
ansprechen darf also ich würde gerne
noch kurz darüber diskutieren was
eigentlich in unserer Gesellschaft
passiert ist in dieser Zeit die
individuellen diskutieren wollen eine
kritische Stimme zu dieser
corona-pandemie und wir werden hier auch
die Frage stellen was ist mit den
anderen kritischen Stimmen wurden die
nicht genug gehört wie viel Einfluss
wurde genommen und diese zu unterdrücken
das gleich unser Thema hier bei 8:15 Uhr
Pause
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht wollen hier ganz richtig was die
Frau Wagner Ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist
das fast total
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst dass wir zu wenig
Stadt haben wir haben zu viel wenn die
alle wegfallen und wir uns gegenseitig
in Berlin Mitte Cappuccinos verkaufen
das funktioniert nicht dann ist mit
Wohlstand aber das ist alles essen als
freiheitsliebender Mensch würde ich
sagen das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss noch
was machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über den Bericht
[Musik]
viele Menschen haben gelitten während
der corona-pandemie vieles ist passiert
und vieles kommt ans Licht die Schulen
etwa die hätten gar nicht erst
geschlossen werden müssen und wie viele
kritische Stimmen kamen eigentlich nicht
zu Wort viel Stoff für eine
Untersuchungsausschuss das sagt wlana
das ist so denn wir haben in den letzten
Jahren müssen wir sagen
wahnsinnsäußerung gehört von
Verantwortlichen die damals in der
corona-zeit verantwortlich waren für die
Bekämpfung der Pandemie allen voran du
hast es erwähnt oder Dealer Robert Koch
Institute Chef der gesagt hat der uns
diese ganzen Schuhe Schließung beschert
hat und auf einmal sagt nein in einem
großen Interview mit der Zeit diese
Schuhe Schließung hätte es gar nicht
Bedarf jetzt gar nicht gebraucht Aldi
Eltern die sich da wirklich Tage Wochen
Monate um die Ohren geschlagen haben die
Stress zu Hause gehabt haben Schrei rein
um diesen ganzen Homeschooling Aufwand
irgendwo umzusetzen neben Arbeiten im
Homeoffice und dergleichen die sagen
vielen Dank wieder aber diese einzig die
kommt viele viele Jahre zu spät genauso
wie der etwas höher Lauterbach der das
noch top indem man erst vor kurz schon
gesagt hat ja manche Corona Kranke die
werden sowieso nie wieder gesund und den
Rat gegeben hat an diejenigen die
ein besonderes gealtertes Immunsystem
haben was immer das ist das sieht nur
noch zwei Corona Impfungen bekommen
sollen und ich werde gesagt hat drei
oder vier also statt vier wie es immer
hier sollen wir nur noch zwei bekommen
auch ein bisschen spät weil die meisten
haben jetzt drei oder vier und erst
gestern enthüllt von Bild übrigens dass
es Gespräche gegeben hat auf höchster
Regierungsebene der Bundesregierung
sogar angeblich mit Bundeskanzlerin
Merkel und den Vertretern von hohen
Internet großen internetkonzernen um
unliebsame Meinungen zu dämpfen da ging
es wahrscheinlich nicht nur um
Verschwörungstheorien sondern sehr viel
Kritisches was im Zuge der
corona-pandemie da in den letzten auf
sich auftürmte und viel viel mehr in
dieser Richtung um ein paar Sachen haben
wir schon gesprochen
so ein Untersuchungsausschuss hat ja
nichts zu tun mit Hetze oder Häme oder
AFD Politik die übrigens ein solchen
Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundes in der
Bundesregierung für die Bundesregierung
im Bundestag fordert aber es gibt einen
solchen Untersuchungsausschuss übrigens
schon in Brandenburg in Sachen Corona
getragen übrigens von Grün und von der
CDU warum nicht auch im Bund denn das
brauchen wir um wirklich klar zu kriegen
klar zu machen auch was ist dran an
diesen Vorwürfen und was gegebenenfalls
nicht
stofffehler kann man da sagen derzeit
für eine Untersuchungsausschuss welches
Problem glaubst du ist das Größte was
würdest du als erstes angehen wollen das
größte Problem ist dass immer mehr
Meinungen
Hinweise kommen dass die Maßnahmen wie
sie auf den Weg gebracht worden sind
offenkundig nicht richtig waren und wenn
er will als sagt Schulschließung hätte
es nicht Bedarf da muss man doch gucken
was war denn die Grundlage für diese
Schulschließungen wenn ähm auf einmal
Karl Lauterbach in bestimmten Fällen nur
noch zwei Impfungen empfiehlt und
wirklich Jahre lang durch die Talkshows
teenage und uns drei bis vier Impfungen
empfiehlt das auch noch als
Gesundheitsminister dann muss man diese
Aussagen klar überprüfen und der gibt es
noch viele viele weitere Sachen bis zu
den Impfstoffen selbst die Masken die ja
in millionenfachzahl dann noch liegen
ich kann verstehen und das habe ich
ausdrücklich das in Sondersituation aber
nicht nun wirklich immer dass man da
auch mal fünf gerade das lassen muss und
dass man sagen muss okay das war eine
besondere Situation hier muss man auch
gucken dass man aus der Lage heraus
entschieden muss und nicht alles wusste
was ich da auftaucht aber es sind so
viele Ungereimtheiten im Nachhinein die
auch eingeräumt werden jetzt von den von
den Verantwortlichen dass ich sage jetzt
ist der Zeit mal wirklich gefakten zu
prüfen und zu gucken was ist zu
hinterfragen und in welcher Form
vielleicht sollte vielleicht kommt er
dabei raus ist alles war alles okay dann
ist ja gut ne wie sehr haben sie
gelitten in dieser Zeit auch als
Künstlerin auch beruflich aber
vielleicht auch privat wie war das für
Sie also ich bin glaube ich echt eine
Ausnahme mir ging super oder nein ich
bin aber ganz ehrlich ich hatte wirklich
nicht einmal Krone also das hat mich
nicht und ähm mir hat es ein bisschen
gut getan jetzt nicht mehr so vielen
Menschen ich bin jeden Menschen sind
machen wir ein bisschen Angst also für
mich war jetzt nicht so schlimm nur mein
Umfeld muss ich sagen das fand ich
schlimm und dieses nicht reisen können
und sowas fand ich schlimm und eben die
Leute die ich um mich rum gesehen habe
weil wenn du eine Panik hast eine
Spritze zu bekommen es gibt ja Menschen
die haben wirklich Angst
welches Medikament nehmen ich weiß ich
ich bin zum Beispiel ein Typ ich bin da
echt schmerzfrei ich habe mich impfen
lassen weil ich das so auch gesehen habe
dass das in Ordnung ist und ich mache
mir da keine weiteren Gedanken aber ich
habe Leute wirklich gesehen die waren da
ich mache das nicht ich will das nicht
warum muss ich das tun das ist Gift
wirklich das ist so wie wenn ich sage
ich spritze mir jetzt irgendein Gift und
das hat mir leid getan und da sind eben
viele Leute psychisch leider echt dran
zerbrochen auch diese Isolation mir hat
es persönlich nichts ausgemacht wenn ich
jetzt ehrlich aber das bin ich ich bin
nicht jeder etwas selbst sie sehen ja
aber auch in ihrem Umfeld das ist ganz
vielen Menschen nicht nur etwas
ausgemacht haben sondern dass sie
natürlich auch leiden Glöckner was
glauben Sie was ist der Punkt wo wir
wirklich ran müssen den der aufarbeiten
müssen wo ist eine Entschuldigung
einfach nicht mehr tut ja also fangen
wir mal bei der Entschuldigung an ja
also bei wenn man sich entschuldigt muss
man erstmal sozusagen um Verzeihung
bitten ja also man muss vortragen und
Sagen aus diesem und jedem Grund bitte
ich um verzeihunger das jetzt nicht
unbedingt getan als ich um
Entschuldigung er hat Fehler
eingestanden er hat aber auch die
schulterpolitik rüber geschoben ja das
ist das typische plain Game dass wir ja
kennen am Ende will keiner gewesen sein
ich meine wir halten uns mal vor Augen
was hier passiert ist in den
Krankenhäusern sind Menschen alleine
gestorben das muss man sich mal
vorstellen in den Altenheimen auch also
ich kenne ja auch eine Familie eine
90-jährige Frau neuen Kinder ich weiß
nicht wie viele Enkelkinder die Frau ist
alleine im Krankenhaus gestorben also
das muss man sich vorstellen
ja es ist besteht eben eine Gefahr und
so weiter und also das wiegt so schwer
ja wir können hier nicht von von
Entschuldigung reden also wenn ich jetzt
mir z.B in den Herrn Spahn an wo der
gesagt hat es gibt kein Anspruch auf
Restaurantbesuch und ja noch vieles
andere mehr da muss ich mir sagen wenn
Herr Spahn sich jetzt um Entschuldigung
bitten würde und der dann sozusagen sein
Handeln auch noch durch eine
entsprechende Handlung dokumentieren
würde oder unterstreichen würde wenn er
zum Beispiel sagen würde ich lege mein
Bundestagsmandat nieder und dann würde
ich sagen okay damit kann ich etwas
anfangen das fange ich vielleicht an zu
respektieren aber jetzt nachdem was hier
passiert ist zweieinhalb Jahre drei
Jahre ein unfassbaren Terror im Land
veranstaltet also Menschen drangsaliert
bis zum geht nicht mehr und sich dann
hinstellen und ja noch nicht mal um
Entschuldigung bitten sondern so eine
Halbzeiten ja es wurden Fehler gemacht
und eigentlich ja die andere Seite ist
der Schuld also ja wie das jetzt der
Luther wieder ähm gesagt hat zum Besten
gegeben hat da jetzt dann einfach auf
ich glaube einfach wieder es ist wieder
die totale Überforderung gewesen das ist
wie eine Massenpanik gewesen das ist auf
die Menschen so zu gestimmt diese
Krankheit und jeder hat sein Senf dazu
gegeben und ich glaube einfach dass
keiner da wirklich damit umgehen konnte
das war zu viel also die Politik ist
halt die Politik ist ist dazu da im
schwierigen Situationen ja mit den
Dingen umzugehen und ja was sich das
Parlament die Parlamentarier
Bundestagsabgeordneten geleistet haben
also auch im Hinblick auf die
Impfpflicht ja das muss man sich mal
vorstellen also wir wissen mittlerweile
dass es Menschen gibt die der Leben ist
gelaufen durch die Impfung ja also alles
deutet darauf hin und Menschen sind
aller Voraussicht nach auch an der
Impfung gestorben und jetzt überlegen
wir mal was es heißt wenn ein Staat eine
Impfpflicht anordnet und um viele
Menschen leben nicht gegeben hat ja
glücklicherweise aber das ja auch das
macht leider nicht besser wenn ein Staat
das macht und weiß dass es hier ein
Risiko gibt dass Menschen einen Schaden
nehmen was passiert dann wie ist dieser
Staat einzuordnen und wir hatten die
Diskussion ja schon beim
Luftsicherheitsgesetz als die Frage war
darf ein Staat einige Menschen töten um
viele zu retten wenn ein voll beladenes
Flugzeug mit 300 Passagieren das Problem
ist die haben sich wahrscheinlich
gedacht da geht ja die Wirtschaft
vollkommen im Bach runter wenn gar
keiner mehr raus kann dann haben die das
mit der Impfung erfunden um dann zu
sagen sie können fliegen mit der Impfung
können Sie dies ich glaube das hat auch
mit Geld viel zu tun dass da irgendwas
überhaupt geht natürlich eine Rolle
gespielt also ich meine ja viele
sprechen auch vom kooperatismus ja der
Verschmelzung von Politik einfach mit
sehr mächtigen Konzernen Großkonzern ja
das ist natürlich ein Thema für sich
aber was ich sagen wollte bei diesem
Luftsicherheitsgesetz war halt die
zentrale Frage darf ein Star diesen
Jumbo mit 300 Passagieren abschließen
wenn der Terroristen sind und der die
Terroristen Vorhaben auf den
Atomkraftwerk zu fliegen und dann halt
mehrere Jahr 10.000 Menschen genau
und da hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht
nein ja das darf ein starten nicht und
ich würde so weit gehen wenn ein Staat
in diesem Fall eine Impfpflicht anordnet
dann wird der Staat meines Erachtens zum
Mörder aber genau diese diese
sagen in demnächst mal die natürlich
auch sehr plakativ sind sie aus ihrer
persönlichen Sicht verstehe ich haben
auch viele viele natürlich Fans die das
so sehen und die jüngsten Ereignisse
geben in hier und daher auch recht aber
da muss man wirklich auch sagen wenn es
alles nicht so war wie sie sagen dann
lässt sich das ja auch aufklären und
wenn sie war dann so droht ein solcher
Untersuchungsausschuss ja auch
gerechterweise die Fakten ans Licht
glaube ich deswegen brauchen wir das das
glaube ich nicht da würde ich ihn wieder
sprechen also ich bin ganz weit ich bin
ganz bei Ihnen ja das ist wichtig ist
dass wir aufklären und ich bin auch bei
ihnen im Hinblick auf und
Untersuchungsausschuss also ich würde
auch sagen das Thema was da passiert ist
ist so groß wir brauchen mehrere
Untersuchungsausschüsse das Problem ist
nur wer soll in diesen Ausschüssen
sitzen also wenn wir ja wir sprechen im
Buch von Corona Tätern ja also es sollen
die Täter selbst die eigenes Tun
aufarbeiten ja also das ist von vorne
rein zum Scheitern verurteilt und müssen
ja auch wie Untersuchungsausschüsse in
der Regel laufen wie die besetzt werden
und so weiter also da bin ich sehr skeps
hat offen mal sehr viel Vertrauen
verloren Sebastian was kann so ein
Untersuchungsausschuss bringen was
können wir auch lernen aus dieser Krise
für die Zukunft ich würde schon sagen
der Parlamentarismus funktioniert da
schon also ein Untersuchungsausschuss
doch kannst du Dinge auch aufklären und
da sind ja Menschen Politiker die haben
auch ein Mandat die sind gewählt und
repräsentieren uns äh das ist das schon
sehr viel pluralistischer als hier
sozusagen angedeutet das würde ich als
naive Sicht bezeichnen das ist ja ihre
Meinung ist auch okay tatsächlich gibt
es aber durchaus viele Bereiche
Untersuchungsausschuss brauchen auch bei
der Russland Politik bei der
Energiewende ja wie wir uns abhängig
gemacht haben von Putin diese ganzen
Sachen auch die Merkels einsame
Entscheidung in der Migrationspolitik
das sind alles Sachen die müssten
eigentlich aufgearbeitet werden und man
sagt aber so schwamm drüber ist jetzt
halt so muss ich sagen auch als Bürger
als Wähler das finde ich nicht in
Ordnung das müsste tatsächlich mal
geklärt werden diese Fragen
Corona ist jetzt irgendwie gar nicht
mehr so wichtig gerade das ist auch so
eine Geschichte also jetzt auf einmal
ist es klar wir haben den Krieg das ganz
schlimm und so aber auf einmal ist
Corona jetzt so ja also man lerne ich
mir jetzt auch warum habe ich geimpft
weil das hätte ich halt aussitzen können
aber ihr Thema ist wichtig weshalb sie
heute da sind es geht nämlich um
folgendes Thema eine Frau wird
verlaufender Kamera beleidigt in der
Hauptrolle Dieter Bohlen das schauen wir
uns noch mal an
ich habe Abitur gemacht und danach
dachte ich mir so was machst du jetzt
ich wollte noch irgendwas cooles machen
Abenteuer erleben das Hauptargument war
das Fame ist weil kann ja nicht
Langeweile gewesen sein Abenteuer
Blumenkohl und Fame irgendwas vernünftig
also normales gemacht irgendwie oder
hast du nur abi und dann dich
durchnudeln lassen
für Patricia Blanco ist dieser Satz ganz
klar eine Grenzüberschreitung und Frau
Blanco sie sind auch heute hier sehr
sammeln sich auf Instagram bereits
ausführlich zu dem Thema geäußert sagen
Sie uns hier in die Kamera was würden
Sie jetzt Dieter Bohlen ins Gesicht
sagen ja ich habe das ja schon auf
Instagram kund getan ich hätte ihm
einfach gesagt wer im Glashaus sitzt
sollte nicht mit Steinen werfen weil er
hat genau von er hat ja auch alles
wieder gepoppt sage ich jetzt mal was
nicht auf dem Baum kam in Hamburg so
habe ich ihn so also wahrgenommen und
ich finde die Art und Weise wie er das
rüber gebracht hat
fand ich jetzt wirklich ein bisschen so
abwertend und für mich ist das
eigentlich also Dieter Bohlen ich kenne
ihn mal nicht persönlich aber es ist so
ein Grundthema sowieso
es gibt so ein Film ich weiß jetzt
werden alle dass es soll nicht wohl ger
sein aber es gibt schon finden da ist
als die Frauen noch Schwänze hatten
sorry das ist jetzt so ein Film wo ich
einfach sagen muss der Ursprung was er
vergisst ist einfach genauso ein Mädchen
kann ihn halt stürzen von seinem Thron
und im Endeffekt arbeitet er aber genau
mit solchen Themen und er ist eigentlich
der Haupt Initiator von sowas und
ergreift eigentlich eigentlich jemanden
an der nichts Böses getan hat und diese
Emanzipation da sehe ich halt dieser
Mann ist komplett prähistorisch das ist
für mich Steinzeit aber das ist ja
leider nicht eher nur sondern da erlebe
ich ja tausend solche Beispiele wieso
darf ein Mädel wenn es Single ist nicht
machen was es will solange ich nicht in
einer Beziehung verheiratet bin oder
jemanden schade darf dieses Mädchen doch
sich austoben was hat es mit dem Abitur
zu tun
also ich nenne jetzt hier keine Namen
oder so aber ich bin auch sehr
prähistorisch aufgewachsen ja ich weiß
was es heißt wenn ein Mann einen ein
Macho ist oder wenn man sie meinen ihren
Vater darüber ich möchte mich da nicht
äußern wie ich damals ist so offenkundig
deswegen wäre es irgendwie
um mich rum als Männer zwei 2023 also da
kann ich jeden Tag z.B nennen der Mann
darf das einfach also beim Mann ist es
voll cool das ist leider immer noch so
das haben sie dafür Sprüche gehört oder
man darf das voll cool wenn ich sowas
sage ja einfach der Mann wird natürlich
nach oben gelobt wenn er eine nach der
anderen sage ich mal ins niedere knallt
und das Mädchen ist halt gleich die
[__] und es ist heute noch so oder
ähm ja ich kann auch zehn Bier trinken
wieder Mann ich bin halt der voll Alki
und der Mann ist total geil weil er
schafft es weil also sind lauter so
blöde Beispiele aber ich finde es halt
wahnsinnig altmodisch und ich finde in
der heutigen Zeit sollte man mit sowas
nicht mehr arbeiten aber das Ergebnis
hat ja gezeigt wir Frauen sind im
Endeffekt ich finde dass wir stärker
sind also vom ganzen vom ganzen her und
das vergisst ebenso jemand und benutzt
dann so eine Plattform die ihm jetzt
eigentlich zum Verhängnis wird obwohl er
selber so gearbeitet eine Frau zeigt
Führungsstärke ein Mann zeigt
Führungsstärke die Frau gilt dann als
Zicke oder weder anders Sebastian ja ich
auch nicht mehr ich gesagt weil ich
nicht ist nicht mehr so also
[Musik]
erlebe ich nicht so aber mag sein dass
das noch so ist aber wollte noch mal
dazu zu diesem aktuellen Fall zurück ich
verstehe auch RTL nicht in diesem ganzen
ich meine diesen Ausschnitt den wir da
gesehen hat den hat ja nie im im
Fernsehen gegeben sondern nur in dem
vorab Stream ähm er hatte er hat am
Anfang erklärt ja ist uns egal ist halt
so gesagt worden jetzt gibt's
Krisensitzung dann haben Sie Dieter
Bohlen rausgeschmissen vorher aus der
Sendung weil sie gesagt haben nein das
geht gar nicht mehr gegen die Quoten in
den Keller dann haben sie wiedergeholt
und jetzt einfach solche Sprüche
natürlich
diese Frau kommt doch Jill heißt sie
glaube ich ne kommt auch nicht zufällig
in diese Sendung und trällerte ein
Mädchen natürlich ist die da rein
platziert worden mit der ganzen
Vorgeschichte und die Vorgeschichte ist
natürlich dass sie an diversen wie sie
ja auch vor Blanco Castingshows und
nicht Casting
gemacht gell das nicht aber verschiedene
sich da exponiert hat so und und und und
das wittert jemand wie Bowlen natürlich
auch und weiß natürlich was eine Rolle
da sein soll und spielt damit und also
insofern ist das ein großes show
business mit dem Schwerpunkt Business
nicht damit gerechnet dass dieses
Mädchen das ist ja eben das damit
rechnet so jemand der in dieser Position
glaube ich ist und er hat damit auch
nicht so gerechnet ihre Reaktion weil
eben sehr stark der der geweint und
alles und das wird natürlich sehr gerne
aufgenommen und ich glaube die halbe
Frauenwelt ist wenn der Bullen alleine
durch den Wald gehen würde würde der
vielleicht das gar nicht überleben weil
17 Frauen hinterherrennen würden das ist
als Problem damit wurde nicht gerechnet
es wird schon sehr stark gespielt es
kommt auf die Kandidatin und es gibt
auch welche die sich einschüchtern
lassen hört man einfach so gesagt ja und
hätten das unter den Tisch gekehrt und
das finde ich eben so witzig man darf
nie spielen mit dem feuern sagen ich bin
ganz oben ich bin Mann ich darf das die
Quote dass es immer das Problem an
diesen Geschichten die können leider
auch so ausgehen und das hat jetzt die
Riesen Debatte aber ich finde es toll
dass sowas ausgelöst wird weil ich finde
es einfach ihr liebes total oft wenn du
als Frau also mir geht's immer so ich
bin ja lauter Mensch ich gebe auch gern
Konter auch in meiner Partnerschaft in
solchen Geschichte
sogar in der Bibel und so zeige ich so
was geht ab Ja oder Nein ja und ich
gerade immer sehr stark am Historiker
und ich bin dann ja jemand der dann
gerne so ein bisschen austeilt und das
stimmt es kommt einfach bei Männern
nicht gut an ja das ist oder bist du
gleich die mannsel oh du bist ein Mann
zwei eine Frau hat sich ruhig zu
verhalten und so die darf das nicht also
ich finde schon sehr witzig wie viel
Sebastian beobachtest du noch von diesem
Historikern die Frau blank oder
schildert in unserer Gesellschaft ich
finde hatte ich die gesellschaftliche
Realität schon doch deutlich geändert in
der vergangenen 20 Jahren aber bei
Brunnen ist es ja so ich habe gelacht
über den Spruch das muss ich sagen das
gebe ich zusätzlich eben noch mal
gesehen habe
nur Werbungen bestellt der kriegt auch
Polen geliefert so und RTL wollte
natürlich diese Art von Sprüchen haben
dass die Frau davon offenbar sehr
getroffen hat das ist menschlich
bedauerlich das muss man sagen weiß
natürlich ehrlicherweise auch wenn er
mit einer Sonne solche Sendung geht was
einem dazu ähm erwarten hat was mich
Ärger bei RTL ist die geben sich ja so
besonders wow ne die Erklärung anderer
Stelle man darf also nicht mehr von
Geschlechtsumwandlung sprechen sondern
von Geschlechtsangleichung man muss also
dieses innen immer sagen und so damit
den Sternchen und so weiter weil sonst
könnte sich ja irgendwie verletzt fühlen
angeblich und so und dann wird das hier
quasi als ein Teil ihres
Geschäftsmodells so ausgestrahlt das
passt nicht zusammen das ist Doppelmoral
aber das ist das Business ich habe
selber erlebt in diesen Show ähm der
wird oft Teufel komm raus ich wurde auch
in manchen ich sag jetzt nicht welche
wirklich animiert du musst jetzt stumm
machen du musst dies also die wollen
natürlich immer diese Quote aber das ist
eben diese Schere zwischen Menschen ist
es Moral echt mal es gibt Leute die
packen es halt nicht die bewerben sich
zwar da dieses Mädchen du füllst ja bei
diesem DSDS und Zettel aus dann lesen
die sich das natürlich durch und wenn
die natürlich schreibe ich habe bei
Temptation alle mitgemacht das ist für
ihn klar geil ja und dann erzähl die
noch was von Abi dann macht er gleich so
einen Film geil die Kombi ist ja der
Hammer aber ich finde die Art und Weise
man kann sie auch anders reden hätte er
so ein bisschen netter gemacht dann
hättest sogar so ausgesehen wie ein
Vater der mit seiner Tochter redet der
sagt hey du hast Arian alles und jetzt
gehst du in so blöde dating Shows willst
du nicht was anders machen das hätte ich
noch witzig gefunden aber das hat immer
sowas ein bisschen diese Tonlage so
abwertend quasi also so ist das
Showgeschäft
es ist nicht so einfach unsere Show ist
zu Ende wir danke Ihnen ganz herzlich
fürs zusehen vielen herzlichen Dank an
meine Gäste ich freue mich aufs nächste
Mal machen gut
[Musik]